[Applause]
good morning believe nation today's
message is take risks over to you John
Lasseter
I wake up every mood in espresso TV go
to create something that connects with
people that moves people is the most
fulfilling and satisfying work there is
for an artist it is it is truly a
privilege to do this for a living but
with that privilege comes responsibility
and the privilege and responsibility are
one in the same to do something new I
say that it is a responsibility because
to really truly be creative you have to
be willing to take risks you have to put
yourself out there you have to be
willing to fail failure has such a
negative connotation in our society and
I think this is totally unfair because
what failure really is is the
opportunity to learn if we never failed
it would never occur to us to do things
differently you just keep doing the same
thing because it would always work but
the world changes people change and so
we have to change we have to fail in
order to succeed so what do you think I
thought it was really interesting
because i resonate with it so well just
having going through tons of challenges
myself he talks about failure and the
only way I feel you could reach failure
is to take the risk the funny thing is
when he said people are afraid of
failure the interesting i found is want
to connect with friends and when I see
people connecting with each other they
seem to connect through the lessons they
learn from the failures and just by the
virtue of that I think it's so important
to take that risk and embark on a
journey where failure could be a
wonderful step you can create a memory
and share with other people and grow and
build with them I think we have
opportunities every day to push our
boundaries a little bit to say yes is
something that we are afraid of so as an
example even you being here right now
you know tuan bought 10 copies of my
book he's in town from Ottawa has a
whole day plan and part of it is being
here and initiate was just coming and
get a book signed and say hi and
and continue on and said hey why don't
we make a video together it was it was
is a risk yeah hate to do it but you
know what I'm gonna do it yeah and so
you have changes every single day to say
yes to an opportunity that may be scary
that may push some boundaries that may
make you you know a little fearful
heinous and a jump yay and the
interesting here thing here is that I'm
you into this world so if you guys are
kind of thinking about something that
you're not familiar with this is
something I'm completely new to in terms
of reaching out to influencers and
really cool people that have inspired me
like Evan and all I wanted was hey why
not just ask for an autograph that's all
I was looking for and who would have
known that taking that risk gave me the
opportunity here on the Express oh this
is sick like this is crazy like it's
amazing a lot of people say no a lot of
people are too afraid we're a lot of
people turn down the opportunity a lot
of people don't even bother reaching out
they say hey I'm coming to town can i
stop by 45 minutes to sign a book they
have a book signing right a lot of
people don't take that risk because
they're just afraid of being rejected
and so you know kudos to you thank you
I'll shared a great game feel good job
that was a great job and for you guys
watching you know the next time you have
that thought is something you want to do
in that voice then comes to mind says me
maybe I shouldn't do it stomp that other
voice out and just give it a shot and
see how it turns out so the question
that they today is what risk are you
gonna take in 2017 I love it leave it
down the comments below and we're going
to join in the discussion so thank you
guys so much for watching we believe in
you and hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love and we'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot a
vinspresso
expresso keep me go guys we're also
looking at doing a top 10 on John
Lasseter here is a sneak peek at some of
the clips that are to come I hope you
enjoy the thing I always tell students
that really wanted to work in animation
we're working film for that matter is do
not forget to study the basics basic
drawing even for computer animation you
should know how to draw basic design the
basic fundamentals of animation where
you learn the principles of animation
film grammar how do you stage things you
know that you know how they do it in
live-action filmmaking story writing
three active story structure is so vital
to this and if you've got to learn all
these basics because this is kind of
like eating vegetables you know a lot of
people don't want to do it they just get
on to the more flashy stuff of using all
the latest software but the thing is is
through your career the software will
change it will always evolve and get the
better what's important in remember this
software never makes a movie
entertaining is what you do with a
software and what you do with a software
it will be will be you know you'll learn
that from the basic fundamentals
you know I rely on these the basic
fundamentals of art and design and
filmmaking and animation and
storytelling you know every single day
of my career it's something that just is
a part of youths the foundation in which
you work and without those you know you
won't go anywhere so it's really
important to get the fundamentals down
loved animation I knew was not just for
kids Walt Disney never made his movies
just for kids he made them for everybody
Chuck Jones made his cartoons to show in
theaters in front of Warner Brothers
movies for adults but I felt it had to
be done for today's audience it had to
be done in a new way I found the answer
when i was working at disney computer
animation I knew this was it I knew this
was the future you see one of the things
that that I always admired about Walt
Disney was his innovative spirit Walt
had been a great advocate of the new and
many ground breaking developments of
film technology had their origins at his
studio I threw myself into suggesting
projects that would show how the
computer could be used to take Disney
Disney Animation to the next level I
even did a test I kept getting the
answers no that's not how it's done is
it cheaper is it faster then no just do
what you're told no one was willing to
take risks but that didn't stop me I
kept trying I just couldn't let go of
the idea that computer animation was
something Disney should be doing because
I knew it'd make this studio and its
films better then one day the manager of
the animation department mr. know
himself called me into his office and
fired me
to be fired from the place of your
dreams was so painful and embarrassing
for me that it took decades before I
could actually tell people about it I
made this kind of excuse up that I
followed my dream somewhere else even as
I got married I it took me a long time
to tell me i see how to actually get my
wife i had actually gotten fired but as
fate would have it I met ed camel of the
Lucas own computer division he and his
group were doing the most innovative
research in the world in computer
graphics and unlike the Disney de just
fired me ed was so excited about what I
was trying to do to combine classic
animation principles to computer
animation I finally found someone who
could see the future as I saw it he
invited me to come work with him then in
1986 Steve Jobs entered our lives he was
so excited about what he what we were
trying to do that he that he bought our
group from Lucasfilm and we formed a new
company cold Pixar he really pushed us
to do what no one else had ever done
before the result in 1995 we released
the first computer animated feature film
ever made we released Toy Story to make
a great film I believe you have to do
three things really well tell a
compelling story that is unpredictable
keeps the audience on the edge of their
seat you populate that story with really
appealing and memorable characters and
put that story in those characters in a
believable world believable for the
story you're telling not realistic we're
not interested in reproducing reality
it's a believable world so those three
components are kind of the guiding
structure of this exhibit you see the
development of the story through our
story boards at Pixar we developed the
story on the the written word on the
script but just in the very beginning
and then we go into creating the
storyboards of the story it's like a
comic book version of the story and
that's where our story is developed you
see lots of that artwork it's very quick
and very rough but it tells the story
it's amazing you know when you know our
films you look up there and you go oh
that's that's the moving it's a
fantastic developing the character
design goes hand in hand with developing
the story and you see many many versions
of certain characters we really do
tremendous amount of experimentation in
this this way so it's a very interesting
and we produce three-dimensional
sculptures of our characters basically
always start with a two-dimensional
drawing but our final product is truly
three-dimensional within the computer
and then the worlds that we create have
to be so believable and we do a
tremendous amount of research for
whatever worlds were creating but we
want you to believe that these worlds
exist on the final screen so you will
see some unbelievable art landscape
paintings drawings deed from tiny
details because in our world character
in a computer animation you get nothing
for free you can't go on location and
shoot a computer anime film everything
is created by the artist at Pixar so you
see where artwork from all of those
three categories